la sieste un moment privilégié défendu
par quelques irréductibles depuis
plusieurs décès dans les années 70
l'homme de lettres yvan audouard se
qualifiait même de propagandistes de
l'assist c'est un exercice qui devrait
être reconnu de salubrité publique
un avis partagé par d'autres si hester
professionnel en 1995
ces policiers du sud de la france terre
de sieste incontestable pesait de ce
moment une priorité moi je veux
seulement la recherche sur le divan
j'arrête bola je m'endors et je me
réveille quand je me réveille 14h à 16h
dans la nature dans les transports en
commun ou directement dans la rue la
sieste se pratique partout et pour
certains politiques les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale font aussi bien la
faire grand spécialiste du genre
l'ancien député raymond barre dont se
moquer gentiment lionel jospin en 1988
c'est vrai qu'on lui a vu faire à
l'assemblée des siestes glorieuse des
siestes béate des repos réparateur
après déjeuner superbe des siestes
d'accord mais pas trop longtemps
quinze minutes pas plus parole de
scientifiques une consigne dont certains
secteurs n'ont que faire vous dormez
longtemps 2h 3h corps est bon 3 heures
c'est que c'est pas très bon pour la
santé dans l'air pour longtemps
d'autres militants de la sieste vont
même jusqu'à l'imposer sur leur lieu de
travail en 2015
cette salariée était à l'origine de
cette salle zen lassé de devoir se
cacher pour se reposer j'ai clairement
fait la ciat sûrement de travail dans
mon véhicule pendant plusieurs mois
avant l'ouverture de cette salle zen
parce que j'étais enceinte et ça ne
m'était vraiment nécessaire pour pouvoir
perdurer dans le temps pour venir
travailler en fait qu'elle soit
pratiquée au travail à l'assemblée ou en
pleine nature le plus dur finalement
avec la sieste
le réveil
[Musique]